allez on reprend depuis le début
la tournée mérignies et l'événement à ne
pas manquer dans trente six heures la
super star kartz valdés est le lauréat
des trainières worth bastian vont
présenter leurs nouvelles chansons mais
ronnie et échanger leur beurre suis mis
devant un public de fins millions de
personnes
tu me reconnaîtras j'aurai un voile sans
hésiter n'arrive qu'une fois dans la
ville et ma fille ce soir ça tombe bien
j'ai trois billets pour ce soir amène la
papa tu t'es pas éclater une seule fois
ce pic maman est parti dit oui à
[Musique]
l'électricité jeu s'est
ralenti on est cinq minutes qu'est ce
que vous regardez tous rien du tout pas
souhaité ont-elles famille le futur mari
de 4 valdez surpris en train de la
tromper avec son assistante
[Applaudissements]
enfin il paraît que 20011 gens vont nous
regarder échanger nos voeux on dit que
si on veut pas ce qui est écrit d'avancé
il faut écrire sa propre histoire
pourquoi pas
oui
[Musique]
je vais épouser toi
monsieur je ne sais pas qui consentent
et vous apprendre 4 pour épouser
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
lundi 4 valdez a laissé le gars du
concert et dans la foulée a épousé son
chauffeur du beurre c'est une situation
insensée on n'a qu'à lui offrir 5000 $
et attendre un peu que ça se passe où je
reste marié à ces dames
j'ai commencé quelque chose hier soir et
si je ne vais pas jusqu'au bout je vais
passer pour une cinglée nous devons
prendre les devants pour
seulement trois mois je ne connais même
pas on a fait ça ensemble que ça nous
plaise ou non on doit être solidaire il
faut qu'on vive ce moment en toute
spontanéité
ce ne peut pas être la risée de tous
et moi j'ai quoi rester là et souriez
c'est vraiment le truc le plus
hallucinant qui puisse arriver dans la
vie
[Musique]
là il ya deux cent trente sept mille
personnes qui trouvent que vous avez une
tête a animé un club d'une battre mais
j'anime un club de battre
en passant c'est sûr nez avec lui j'ai
eu l'impression d'être
normal et si vous venez avec moi au bal
d'automne vous êtes en train de
m'inviter à la soirée du lycée bah je
peux vous laisser un mot d'ordre quasi
appelée si vous vous sentez seul à l'eau
encore qu elle retomber amoureuse de
bastian et qu'elle te larguer
moi aussi j'en ai peur il faut arrêter
de se raconter les histoires je ne suis
pas à ma place
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est raisonnable
ça fait six semaines que cela n'a plus
aucun sens
samedi
[Applaudissements]
elle doit pour qui tu t'en un fan non je
suis pas un fan jeu enfin si maintenant
[Musique]